to to kind of warn people if you will
what is your evaluation as we sit here
kind of mid-may of just what's
transpired right we're not to go in tons
of detail you know people obviously know
a lot of this but but just kind of
what's your general evaluation of that
health crisis so you know I've treated
some of this and I'm writing a bunch of
long-form stuff for tribal which I will
drop at some point but act one was and
is the virus crisis which is ongoing Act
two is the financial crash and act three
I think is a crisis of our institutions
and I really think that we are in for
some crazy stuff and I you know I think
I called some of these aspects actually
pretty early on but I think the new
political axis or you know whether you
want to call it trade-off access or
what-have-you will worldwide is you know
antivirus and pro-freedom okay so those
are like kind of like the two polls you
might call it the total state versus
market anarchy okay and the so what's
what's kind of going on here so we're in
the middle of this huge political
realignment where old issues just don't
matter as much
and things are rotating and new
coalition's are forming even if there's
some old party labels or things like
that and I think you can identify those
two camps as centralization versus
decentralization as modern monetary
theory versus BTC as you know the the
state versus the network as you know
kind of mandatory versus free and you
know health versus wealth okay so it's
actually interesting to think of those
as kind of opposite poles in the sense
that the state is you know two actor
that is now pushing quarantine xand it's
you know it's enforcing stay-at-home
orders you know masks being mandatory
all the type of stuff and there's a
genuine argument for it
in the sense that um you know many many
previous positions or presuppositions
rather that people have about okay you
know my neighbor can do their thing and
it doesn't matter so long as it doesn't
affect me completely break down in a
coronavirus world where if your neighbor
is not taking precautions you very well
could get sick and so you have an
interest in their health in a way that
you just didn't before now in a sense
arguably that's good because you know
okay well I have an interest in in their
health I will help them stay healthier
and keep myself healthier at the same
time there's you can make an argument
from a skin in the game or a lineman
standpoint that you know community
people who care about each other's
health will probably be better you're
just like you know you're part of a
fitness club or whatever you know and
and you know people live together and
that's actually good right so but let's
call this one axis right the total state
and that's you know the lock down Abu
Haan that is the you know surveillance
of folks who you know with yellow and
green and red codes not just in China
but other places that's price controls
etc okay now on the other side is market
anarchy and this is essentially the
polar opposite of that and this is to
caricature in extremis it is you know
don't wear a mask but or I should have
the choice as to whether to wear a mask
it is you know like the laws are
necessarily bad everything the state is
doing is wrong etc and you know in and
but the good aspect of it is look we're
going to need to decentralize we're
going to need to encrypt we're going to
need to protect privacy and we're going
to need to have a free market because
the state may protect health at the
expense of wealth to such an extent that
folks are giving silly orders you know
to cease masks seize hand sanitiser
to impose price controls to ban people
from selling things at Walmart and
Target to stop uber eats from doing
things you know his weren't even
proposed like banning mas or whatever
over a certain size those things have
nothing to do with
controlling the virus whatsoever and
their things and of course printing
trillions of dollars right um
and so there's legitimate abuses and
failures on the side of the total state
that the kind of Anarchy pole will will
correct and push against and I think
either of these two poles is probably
bad